là quand je vois festival en plein air
si moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir un pass
annie terre ça veut dire que je peux pas
aller cavalaire au bord de la mer va
garder un festival en plein air je vois
pas les prêtresses dans un théâtre je
peux pas aller dans un établissement
sportif au casino perd je vais pas au
casino
je peux pas aller dans un rassemblement
de plus d'animaux permettent d'aller
dans ton salon je veux me le 19 juin
oui je le fais à 999 personnes parce que
de larges et je rappelerais salutaire à
dire les gens qui de toute l'équipe qui
travaille ici j'étais avec eux tout à
l'heure je les connais presque tous pas
de sept ans leur nul à la finlande
arrive un an oui mais disent mais si je
suis pas vexé les je peux pas travailler
à bien sûr je veux juste finir parce
qu'en plus ils nous l'ont expliqué tout
à l'heure dans la notice là que vous
avez envoyé là le dock nos reportages là
vous avez dit en plus si vous voulez
voyager sous réserve de certains pays
qui vous demanderont quand même une
quarantaine à cause du variant mais à
dire quoi ne pas s'y sert à rien parce
qu'on va te mettre quand même en
quarantaine directement situées à l'est
que tu attrapes commun avec le vide tu
te retrouves en quarantaine de convives
jean-paul rien alors jean paul hamon si
on fonce et quand même si ce sont quand
même des des préoccupations vraiment de
de luxe quoi non c'est vraiment des
stars célèbrent le sincèrement
sincèrement je peux vous dire que les
soignants les médecins en majorité ce
sont vaccinés d'entrée de jeu et après
il a fallu discuter avec les infirmières
et avec les aides soignants mais mais
mais mais je peux vous dire que ça c'est
c'est absolument indispensable si on
veut continuer à mener une vie normale
80% mais c'est à dire c'est obligatoire
attends 80% des français veulent se
faire vacciner 75 118 je comprends pas
où est votre père là parce que vraiment
c'est quand même assez dans l'essonne
précisément le prochain single tendance
à trop de failles isr ne fait pas vrai
c'est totalement est ce que c'est ça et
là mais n'a pas pu participer à la fête
de l'indépendance d'israël parce que ils
ne savent ils ne se fait pas mettre son
de la preuve axa n'a été sabrée sablais
vacciner bien sûr
et tu sais tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]